[Music]
and still alive news you gotta keep
telling them somebody by Jake hey come
to Narnia
okay newts were they're there right now
mm-hmm I go to when I walk in through
the closet all the time the Wardrobe the
Wardrobe Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
so you come out of the closet quite
often we would all have to come out of
the closet once we go there yep sure I'm
staying in the closet in Russian parents
discovered their baby is alive seven
years after being told it had died what
kind of black market baby selling
[ __ ] is this
what happens which is a crazy place
you've been there I was there for a
layover and everyone was like they want
to kill themselves I wonder if they
think we're crazy over we're too happy
yeah because I'm here like you're used
to like customer service whatever every
time I buy something there they say
you're not supposed to smile cuz and you
just look foolish it's like what are you
giggling about all the time like why do
you that's a different culture after
culture yeah it's so strange no wonder
they could give me the dirtiest look I
can't help but smile it yeah yeah
they're like you're look foolish like
what is what's so funny so you know
every year like if you're not smiling
that's like [ __ ] face so for them they
probably have resting smiley face I
think dumbass face [ __ ] idiot with
the resting smiling face looks so cool
yeah that's funny when cultures don't
understand each other and take it
offensively yeah it's really funny
they're so stupid man
I think it's even funnier that like New
Yorkers in LA people can't mix is that
even the same future LA stereotype is oh
you still think yeah and what's the bay
area stuff there is really chill yeah
various so you so relaxed relaxed for
the kind of your soul your soul activist
hipster activist a lot of it starts from
San Francisco in the Bay Area I feel
like the girls in the bay are known
they're kind of not like hood but
they're down to fight like that's what
I'm and I know that what I know Bay Area
girls for I just like Bay Area's
everyone wears Patagonia or some [ __ ]
you know what everyone wears Patagonia
and they drink Pete's coffee I thought
that was you Seattle sound like that's
Renault my Patagonia Bay Area everyone
still wears like Jordans and it's like
the Filipino look with Jordans and like
fitted caps they have their own like
world they're like in their own bubble I
like so this story starts in 2011 when
this woman or they call her a young girl
so I'm not sure how old she was when she
gave birth but a young girl gave birth
at a hospital in Russia but then soon
after the baby was born the hospital
people were telling her that the child
was not viable and that would probably
not survive the week and so they advised
her to give up the child she didn't want
to but eventually she agreed she signed
a waiver leaving the newborn in the care
of the hospital and the state we she
ended up going home then five days later
she felt so guilty that it overwhelmed
her to the point where her the two
parents they went back to the hospital
to retrieve the baby but then Hospital
told them that the baby had died
oh so really happy was they sold the
baby no what really happened was that
the baby ended up going to an orphanage
and they forgot or they just said they
just lied it seems like all of this was
down to a clerical error of some sort
like some sort of like random
administrative error damn what's up and
then the baby did ancestry.com and then
yeah find the baby though because the
kid went to an orphanage the federal
bailiffs service the FSK P they received
a document saying that the couple owed
the states about four thousand one
hundred dollars in unpaid bills by
having and by boarding the child at the
orphanage so that's when bailiffs were
dispatched to go collect from the couple
and then that's when the couple found
out seven years later seven years later
well good thing it was in 26 years later
right specific but you still get a
seven-year-old baby look at the bright
side cuz mistakes happen so this is so
strange they sign the papers over but
yet they were still held accountable for
this bill that's why I don't believe in
hospitals
oh you popped that [ __ ] baby out like
in a log cabin in the wind that's how
you know it's yours the only way to know
if I have a [ __ ] baby in the hospital
I'm following that [ __ ] so you
can't be here shut the [ __ ] up that's my
[ __ ] baby I'm gonna be like one of
these like like a nosy white neighbor
like [ __ ] like this like you have the
baby in the room so you see it there and
they do the testing and all that in the
room so it never leaves a room boy what
about you sit in that room in the movies
with like all the babies when the
parents are too lazy to take care of
their own oh really
I didn't ethical all system that might
be all - so you do have a nursery though
oh they do yeah Isaac they offered me
like oh if you want to get rest for your
first night like after giving birth
oh then we can take into the nursery oh
my hell most women would say no to that
but in the movies there's always a ton
so I don't even know anymore yeah yeah
I've seen those when you go to that
[ __ ] big-ass window and there's a
[ __ ] baby I cannot do that and then
they're always like fellas like parents
my right there yeah I think I think it
could be an updated like a scientific
type of study that happened where they
say that you have to bond with the baby
because they push that so hard that's
like the matrix you know when they have
a [ __ ] human farm I look at that [ __ ]
and I'm like I don't know which [ __ ]
maggot is mine it's the one with the
baby pompadour she looks exactly like oh
yeah baby the same hair and everything
no but yeah so I actually told the story
a little bit wrong at the end so what
happened was the bailiffs when they went
to go look for the couple they went to
the home that the address was listed
they didn't live there anymore so they
put a freeze on their bank accounts
that's how they found out way more yeah
oh yeah so that's how they found out
about
can they sue that's what they're looking
into or it's not being reported but
there's the media speculating like this
is probably what they're gonna be no
yeah so the hospital should pay for it
yeah but their mom and the child must
have been in so much agony oh yeah the
heartache who's not pain man you even
like process that information like hey
you're maybe still alive actually like
seven years later with the eyes like why
would they take so long to collect that
show because it's government stuff we
all know the government things take
forever they take forever to process a
refund but once you're late on something
there on your ass forever you know
what's sad pizza companies work faster
than the government that's just sad I
mean pizza is a lot easier then the
government but they make more money the
government makes way more money they
take money from all of us
not everybody orders pizza Bernie works
[ __ ] fast they do work pretty fast
ain't got as much money as a government
the government got [ __ ] trillions of
dollars they still suck by the time the
pizza gets to you still warm
yep imagine if the government delivered
pizza all right yeah yeah but that's
true though when they want money they're
on your asses like damn what happened
here yeah but it's like so as a mom when
she finally saw the documents from the
orphanage she fainted did you do one of
these you know the movies girls always
feel like this oh I remember being a
little girl every time I would watch a
novela every time the woman would faint
isn't every single novella yeah it's
like oh it's just pregnant they'll be
like they're like oh she's pregnant I've
never seen anyone faint pretty in real
life ever yeah it's always yes and a
[ __ ] stock comes out it's a lot of a
drooling [ __ ] yeah but the video Wendy
Williams passing out yeah
she said like a stroke or something
right she's fainted for something here
hmm my friend she fainted from a seizure
and it looked like she was [ __ ] in
hell dude well she seasoned or she just
fainted she fainted and then went into a
seizure whoa oh my friend to not start
foaming up that's what happened to Biggi
she was I think she had something in
your in her head she was explaining
about like if she doesn't get enough
sleep or something then it triggers
something oh that's me that's why that's
why I sleep so much you do okay
justifying your sleep I'm really
justifying everything as much as I could
right now sleep is good but too much
will kill you see about that are they
reunited now are they happy yeah luckily
the judge granted them full custody of
the minor to the biological parent good
they don't have to pay that [ __ ] bill
did I mention that in the article I
would sue for that I would sue for
emotional distress I would see the
emotional distress for my baby my
husband me my grandmother everyone would
you want your kid back I'll be like I
miss out on everything I want to start
over but it really wouldn't I don't know
you wouldn't no no no I do gotta work
extra hard to reprogram you man I wanted
to program you from the start
I don't even know who these [ __ ] at
the orphanage like mess with your head
and [ __ ] or you can think of it like oh
cool I don't have to train you like no
no no no I want to brainwash them mmm
from this scarf there's no answer
brainwash but they might have picked up
some habits that I don't agree with you
know like table manners you're using
[ __ ] utensils who [ __ ] taught you
to use the [ __ ] outside fork first we
don't do that in the family we eat
everything with knives get the legally
turning back - it's like paper clips no
and [ __ ] oh my god that's even better
yeah I knew you could do the job god I
did a make of that you made up that name
but you added snow which is so much
classier and such a Joe touch paper
clips no paper clips now on paper clip
Joe so cute paper clips mm-hmm
[Music]